now there's a bunch of ways you could
solve this but i think what you'll find
is most useful
is to actually take tan of both sides
now that may seem rather
counter-intuitive to you you're like
where did this come from well i'm going
to show you in a second why this is a
useful thing
now first let's just write down the line
tan of
all of that stuff on the left hand side
equals 10
of pi on 4. okay now why am i doing this
well i want you to
recall that in order to work out um
you know what's what an argument is and
its relationship
to the original complex number um if you
were to say let's just do something a
bit messy over here
if you were to say have some number a
plus i b
and you wanted to relate that to the
modulus right what you would do is you
would say oh well i have a right angle
triangle
sort of implied here right and there's a
right angle here right next to the
positive real axis
and so if i'm after this angle in here
then what i need to do is say
if this is um a plus ib then
this distance here must be a and this
distance here must be b so you can see
the best trigonometric ratio that
relates these two together
is going to be tan because tan of theta
will be b
over a let me say that again tan of
theta
right so tan of your argument that
you're after is going to be b
over a so what i can say is that um tan
of some complex number right
or rather tan of theta which is the
argument
of a plus ib
that should just be equal to tan of
theta which is b
over a opposite on adjacent so i'm going
to go ahead and write in
b over a there so i'm going to say since
tan of arg a plus i b equals b on a
i can actually do some working here
because these tens are going to be able
to
get rid of all of the the argument
notation that sort of has that
the why which i'm after kind of nestled
inside all this messy stuff okay
so i'm going to use this fact to then
say okay well what is
tan of the argument of each of these
complex numbers and they will come into
play later
on so since tan of arg a plus ib equals
b
on a i can say tan of
arg of i y minus 1
that's going to be b over a except
what's b
and what's a in this situation well b is
the
imaginary component which in this case
is y
and then what is a a is the real
component of this
complex number so the real component
here is negative 1.
so i'm going to have y over negative 1
which of course i can simplify
as negative y so i'm going to
you know tuck that away i will refer to
that after i've gotten the rest of this
line in terms of tan
so i'm going to tan of the other
argument now which was
if you recall i y plus 1.
so what's that equal to well the
imaginary component's the same so the b
is the same so it's y over and in this
case my a is not negative 1 it's
positive 1. okay so therefore i get y
now this is good this enables me to work
out what 10 of these arguments
is but just watch out here right i i
can't just put tan
on each of these as if like i've got a
set of brackets that i can just expand
this is actually a um a compound angle
right i can say
but tan of a compound angle like
a minus b and that's the situation
you've got here right
arg of iy minus 1 it's some angle and i
can call that angle capital a
and arg of iy plus 1 is some other angle
and i can call that angle bs in fact i
might even
label that as so call this a and b you
can go the reference sheet for this but
maybe you remember this result
off the top of your head if you've done
this recently in your other course it's
going to be tan a
minus tan b and then it's all divided by
1 plus tan a
tan b so i'm going to have to use all of
this information
in order to work with this line here so
let's try and put this in summary right
i'm going to call this
line 1 or equation 1. i'm going to call
this one two
i'm going to call this one three and
then i'll call this one
four right so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to take uh because i need all
of them right
two and three and four and i'm going to
substitute them into
one because that's the situation i've
got i've got a tan of a minus b
um it's going to become this but then in
order to work out what tan a and tan b
are i need my results from two and three
okay so let's have a go
substitute those three results
two three and four
into my main line of working which is
one all right what do we get
on the left hand side it's going to be
like i said this situation
so tan of a minus b in the first
instance up the top i'll get tan of a
thankfully i've already worked out what
that is it's minus y so
i'll write that at the top then the next
thing is i've got to do -10
b well my b in case in this case is here
so tan of
hug i y plus one i've also worked out
it's just
y so i've got tan a already written like
so and then i'm going to
subtract tan b which is just y
okay so far so good on the left hand
side i'm still doing the denominator
here
i've got 1 plus 10 a tan b which we've
just noticed is
minus y times y
all right that's the left hand side i've
used 2
3 and 4 in order to do this and on the
right hand side i've just got tan of pi
and 4 which is a nice exact angle
that is just 1. all right so we've done
a huge amount of work here right we have
gotten rid of
all the complex stuff out of here all
the arg notation all of that
and i have something which i am able to
um you know
evaluate just in cartesian terms and
remember the reason i'm doing all of
this is because
i am after where did it go here it is
i'm after some
imaginary intercepts some intercepts on
that y direction so i've let x
equal 0 and that's why there are no x's
in this equation
let's start to simplify so i've got on
the numerator minus 2y
on the denominator i've got 1 minus y
squared
and this one is just hanging over on the
right hand side
multiplying through by 1 minus y squared
i've got minus 2y and then 1 minus y
squared on the right hand side
and then because i know where i'm going
what i'm going to do is i'm going to add
y
squared to both sides that leaves 1
on the right hand side but at the same
time because i know i'm trying to solve
for y i could go to the quadratic
formula but i'd rather not
i'm sort of set up to do a completing
the square thing here right
so i'm going to take the coefficient of
y i'm going to halve it which gives me
negative 1.
i'm going to square that which gives me
positive 1. so that's what i
add to both sides i've now successfully
completed the square on the left hand
side which gives me y minus 1 l squared
and i just get 2 from 1 plus 1 on the
right hand side
ready to take the square roots of both
sides that gives me plus or
minus square root of 2 and now i add
1 to both sides and i get this result
1 plus or minus the square root of 2.
now this is really really useful to me
for
two reasons number one uh one of these
results
one minus three two or one plus root two
one of these results is
my y intercept that i'm after and just
having a look at our rough diagram up
above here
you can tell which one it is right root
2 is about 1.4 so 1 minus root 2
is 1 minus 1.4 so in other words it's
actually
going to be down here because of course
what we're solving represents the whole
circle so that's this negative point
down here which we actually
do not want because not part of the
locus or the graph that we've been
generating i want
the other solution which must clearly be
1 plus root 2. so i'm going to make
a statement to that effect i'm going to
say but
on the locus that we generated y has to
be greater than 0.
therefore y equals 1 plus
root 2 only so this is very handy to me
it means i can go to this which i've
drawn a little
more neatly than the other one i had
before and i can say that y-intercepts
up above
i can i can simply state this is uh
one plus root two but do note that this
is actually like we're thinking about
this
um on the complex plane so actually it's
one plus root two
i because that's what takes you in the
vertical direction so that's really
great um i have a
um a y intercept which is fantastic but
i'm not going to abandon that other
solution right
1 minus root 2 is down here now the
reason why this is useful to me is
because it gives me this other piece of
information which i need
to get the cartesian equation um in
order to work out where the center of
this circle is
the there's a lot of different paths you
can go about doing this i used a bunch
of geometric
reasoning deductive reasoning methods in
class before but i actually have
everything i need in this line up here
if y equals 1 plus or minus root 2
then there are two intercepts on the
imaginary axis
and they're both starting from 1 and
then you move root 2
up or root 2 down now that's exactly how
we define
points on the circumference of a circle
you start from a central point and then
you go out
a constant distance which we of course
call the radius so therefore i can say
that 1 plus or minus root 2 in this case
because my circle is centered on the
imaginary axis
1 must be the center or rather one in
the imaginary direction because remember
y is an imaginary component
and then plus or minus root 2 that gives
me the magnitude
of the radius right so therefore i can
say
if i go root 2 down you know this is my
point
i because it's y equals 1 so 1 i that's
my
center and therefore i can you know
reason from there
and i did this in class as well that if
i went to any of the other points on the
circumference and i currently only know
two you can see the distance across each
of these
if i've correctly evaluated this it has
to be equal to
root 2 because that's the whole idea of
a radius it's a consistent measurement
all around
and sure enough if you have a look at
this this is 1 plus root 2 i
take away i that distance has to be root
2 using the fact that this is a right
angle triangle and it's also
isosceles you can see that this is going
to be
also route 2 and by symmetry this is
also
route 2. so this is all i need now to
generate what the
cartesian equation is i've got the
center it's uh you know in terms of
cartesian coordinates it's at 0 comma 1
but in complex coordinates it's i so i
can say that
the circle will be of the form i don't
need brackets there
x squared plus y minus
1 or squared because you can see i've
moved up one unit
and then i can say on the right hand
side it should be a radius
of root 2. so on the right hand side i
have r squared so in this case it's just
2. so that is my cartesian equation and
you can see
i wasn't able to completely avoid
geometric reasoning but
in terms of how to find this uh this
intercept up here
you can still use all of these tools so
long as you know a bit of trigonometry
um and thinking through it so i hope you
found that useful
as i mentioned right at the top of this
i wouldn't recommend this as the first
thing that i would go to
i think that geometric reasoning is far
more efficient and powerful of course
you have to actually include some of
that
in your working but i still think it's
much less error prone
and also far more elegant than having to
go through all this algebra in this very
very
long and circuitous path